i found out there are guys out there who
have tiny penises and
i imagine those guys
imagine those guys get to have sticks
[Applause]
i didn't know i was going to play off
but i really apologized
so i imagine those guys get to have sex
i imagine it's probably pretty awkward
for everybody involved so
this is a song about a dude with a tiny
penis
[Applause]
having awkward sex
and it's from his point of view and this
song is not about me okay here we go
hey guys if you don't laugh at this
we're all going to assume why so yuck it
up
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
be patient i haven't
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Music]
please say something
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i've been told that it's skinny but it's
stronger
[Music]
[Applause]
here it comes guys
maybe your vagina's kinda big
[Applause]
you know what i really liked
you didn't just do big you went kinda
with the face
because that's what the word said kinda
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
another day another dollar howler 7 pm
once again i'm breaking up the birds